Historically probably the first architectural style that became pervasive
was called the Master Control. That issued right at top level routine that was
responsible for organizing the use of the lower level routines.
Some of the other ones listed on this particular list listed here.
Are more recent message bus is an analogy with the bus, the hardware bus
that organizes computations on a chip message bus often means asynchronous
message passing over some common data channel. With your smartphone or
other mobile devices there are a set of constraints that you have to deal with.
That you wouldn't have to deal with in other kinds of applications. So
architectural style in support of mobile code. Where there might be
remote remote evaluation and you have agents of various places on a network
is an example of mobile code architecture and style.
The term object-oriented architectural style is a little bit different, than,
object-oriented programming or object-oriented programming language. But
with the object-oriented architectural style, we still have objects, but
each of those objects have an independent existence that is
they're running all the time, they have their own thread of control, and
they're sending message to each, messages to each other. Assynchronous messages.
This will allows them to cooperatively address a,
address the problem being solved. Peer to peer network, you may have heard of.
Here there are equal parties sharing responsibility for
providing whatever services. Plug in architecture. If you are familiar with some
interactive development environments like Eclipse, you know that there's a whole
registry of available additional functionality that you can plug into Eclipse.
And the mechanism for doing that is a very powerful way of adding extensibility
to systems. Pipe and filter you've seen before with a quick a quick exercise.
One you haven't seen probably, is process control. Think here,
nuclear reactor. Think here, your speed control on your car.
The situation is you have some ongoing hardware process and
you'd like a corresponding software. Application to control that process.
If the process is going too fast, you want to slow it down. If it's going too
slow, you want to speed it up. This is called process control, and its key
element is some kind of feedback loop. From the artificial intelligence world,
there's production systems. These are essentially a collection of rules, and
the conditions under which the rules fire. It enables the modeling of
systems where we don't have a clear idea of what the control flow needed to
implement the system. A very popular one these days is, is Rest.
Rest stands for representational state transfer and
you could think here it's those internet applications that are using HTTP.
that, often have a client server type relationship, and that are stateless,
that is each of the, user requests are handled independently,
and some potentially some caching going on to improve performance.
Service oriented architecture or SOA, is where we have carved up
the functionality of the system into separate services. That is,
from the users point of view, a service is a unit, a self contained unit of, of,
of functionality and that means that we have to imagine the architecture
of the system as being able to support a set of, a set of services.
These are typically done in support of enterprise type applications, and
often with internet connectivity between the user requests through some browser,
and the ultimate service being provided by some server. Shared nothing is
a term for a distributed database with no sharing across across the nodes.
I don't have, personally have, a lot of experience with that one.
Stay transition systems, on the other hand, are very common,
particularly if yo have a situation where the system is driven by events,
assynchronise events, and has to react to those events. A typical example is,
if you've got a GUI and the user is providing the events. But
it could also be some kind of real time system where the events are coming from
the outside world. Shared memory, we saw from the, from the quick exercise and
finally we have table-driven interpreter. For certain kinds of applications
where the requests take the form of simple expressions in some kind of
language we can deal with those requests by having a, an interpreter.
The interpreter is essentially taking the request parsing it, and then invoking
the, whatever procedure is required to deal with that sp, specific request.